-Guys, I don't know
if you heard about this,
but I read that lately,
Amazon has been trying
to crackdown on fake
product reviews.
Well, luckily you can usually
tell when a review is fake.
I'll show you what I mean.
It's time for "Amazon reviews."
Here we go.
-♪ Amazon Reviews ♪
-So, for each product,
I'm gonna show you
the fake review
and then the real review, okay?
First up, here's
an avocado slicer.
Fake review says, "The easiest
way to cut avocados."
The real review says,
"By the time I figured out
how the hell this works,
the avocado was brown."
-What?
-Holding it wrong?
-Cut it?
-"You hold it by the blade."
-"Squeeze the blade hard."
[Laughter]
-Next up, here's a Yeti tumbler.
The fake review says,
"Keeps drinks cold for hours."
Real review says, "This is why
your soccer mom friend
is slurring her words by the
second half of the game."
Here's a disposable
coverall suit.
Fake review says,
"I wear one of these
any time I work with chemicals."
Real review says,
"I wear one of these
anytime I go to Florida."
-Really?
-That's what they said.
Next up, here's a ring light
for shooting videos.
Yeah, the fake review says,
"Makes my videos
look super professional."
The real review says,
"Makes it even more sad
that my TikTok only got
six views."
Took me an hour.
-Aw!
It looked great.
-It took me two hours
to do that.
Next up, here's a set
of dog boots.
Fake review says, "My dog loves
wearing these on the beach."
Real review says,
"I tried putting these on my dog
and he somehow gave me
the middle finger with his paw."
-Wow.
-I don't know.
-Next up, here's a taco
sleeping bag.
Fake review says,
"Comfortable and fun."
Real review sats, "It breaks
the second you fold it.
Should've gotten
the soft shell."
And that's --
-Now you know.
All right, now, next up,
here's a Potty Putter
Toilet Time Golf Game.
[Laughter]
The fake review says,
"This was a perfect
Father's day gift."
Real review says, "I love
playing golf on this,
but my caddies keep quitting."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Yellow ball.
-Next up, here's a Thanos
bathing suit.
[ Laughter ]
Fake review says,
"I love Marvel,
so this was a great buy."
Real review says, "I wish
I could snap my fingers
and make my kids unsee this."
And finally, here's a Wyze
smart scale.
Fake review says,
"It's great to be able
to track my progress
on my phone."
Real review says,
"Now I have two devices
that must be wrong."
That's all for "Amazon Reviews."